das ist wirklich eine besorgniserregende
entdeckungen die könnte zu einer
weiteren katastrophe führen das
havarierte kernkraftwerk tschernobyl
strahlt immer stärker irgendwas im
inneren hat begonnen aber was was
passiert da also im raum 305 zwei klicks
um science im future gibt es dreimal pro
woche spannende science videos abonniert
den kanal und activity glocke nur so
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's
herzlich willkommen
ein katastrophaler nuklearer unfall kurz
nach ein uhr nachts am 26 april vor 35
jahren also 1986 im reaktorblock 4 des
kernkraftwerkes tschernobyl rund 100
kilometer nördlich der ukrainischen
hauptstadt kiew ein test war
fehlgeschlagen und die explosion des
reaktors kostete am unfallort im
atomkraftwerk selbst gleich 50 menschen
das leben doch damit nicht genug die
freigesetzte strahlung dieses tausende
menschen erkranken schätzungen gehen von
4.000 bis 100000 opfern aus die zahl ist
nur sehr schwer zu beziffern weil in
europa viele menschen in der folge an
krebs gestorben sind in bonn standen
zehntausende menschen bei dem event
rhein in flammen ungewohnt stunden in
einem fallout in radioaktivem regen doch
es gab weitere tragödien hunderttausende
menschen mussten ihre häuser verlassen
sie wurden zwangsumgesiedelt große
regionen in russland belarus und der
ukraine sind verstrahlt noch heute sind
gebiete um den reaktor so hoch
kontaminiert dass eine sperrzone
aufrecht erhalten werden muss diese darf
nur mit genehmigung betreten werden der
unfall gilt als die grösste
atomkatastrophe überhaupt denn
radioaktives material wurde in die
atmosphäre geschleudert und zehn tage
lang wurden große mengen von
radionukliden freigesetzt die wolke aus
radioaktiven partikeln bis nach
mitteleuropa und bis zum nordkap große
teile der ukraine russlands und
weißrusslands wurden verseucht der regen
spülte die radioaktiven partikel aus der
atmosphäre auf die erde auch deutschland
blieb nicht verschont besonders heftige
regenschauer
in den tagen nach dem gau vor allem in
bayern baden württemberg und in teilen
brandenburgs dadurch wurde der süden
deutschlands deutlich mehr kontaminiert
als der norden und auch heute noch ist
die strahlung vor tschernobyl bei uns in
deutschland messbar erst kürzlich hatte
das bundesamt für strahlenschutz den
aktuellen pilz bericht herausgegeben und
davor gewarnt dass vor allem in
süddeutschland einige pilzarten stark
erhöhte mengen des radioaktiven isotops
cäsium-137 aufweisen und das stammt
immer noch aus dem reaktorunfall in
tschernobyl vor 35 jahren die
radionuklide cäsium 137 und strontium 90
sind beispielsweise erst etwa zur hälfte
zerfallen andere radionuklide haben
zudem noch deutlich längere
halbwertszeit in der fachsprache ist
damit die zeitspanne gemeint die es
dauert bis sich die ursprünglich
vorhandene menge halbiert hat vor allem
das langlebige cäsium 137 ist mit seiner
halbwertszeit von etwa 30 jahren dafür
verantwortlich dass noch
landwirtschaftliche erzeugnisse und wald
produkte radioaktiv verseucht sind
betroffen sind in deutschland vor allem
gebiete wie südbayern und der bayerische
wald in landwirtschaftlich genutzten
böden ist das problem der cäsium 137
kontaminationen übrigens nicht so groß
der grund dass vor allem waldböden
betroffen sind hier bleibt das cäsium in
einem sehr wirkungsvollen er
stoffkreislauf eingebunden csu ist also
in schichten die viele nährstoffe und
bodenorganismen aufweisen leicht
verfügbar gemeint sind damit sogenannte
organische auflage schichten aus humus
und sich zersetzen im streu pilze
pflanzen und bodenorganismen nehmen das
c 737 auf und führen es wieder den boden
zu und jetzt 35 jahre später ist die
gefahr vor ort in tschernobyl immer noch
nicht gebannt ist droht sogar eine
weitere katastrophe und auch deutsche
fachleute haben messungen in der
sperrzone von tschernobyl durchgeführt
und die ersten ergebnisse verheißen
nichts gutes tschernobyl strahlt
offensichtlich weiter um die reaktor
reste von denen niemand weiß was in
ihnen vorgeht scheinen wieder aktiv zu
werden und strahlen sogar stärker wie
kann das sein und was bedeutet das
konkret alle wichtigen facts zu diesem
thema gibt es jetzt hier praktisch zum
im future deutschland hat vor zehn
jahren den schlussstrich gezogen als
reaktion auf die reaktorkatastrophe von
fukushima hatte die deutsche politik
beschlossenen schneller aus der
atomenergie auszusteigen als
ursprünglich geplant bis ende des jahres
2022 sollen die letzten deutschen
kraftwerke stillgelegt werden anders
dagegen sieht das bei unseren nachbarn
aus polens konservative regierung plant
den massiven einstieg in die atomenergie
und die beiden standorte für
kernkraftwerke liegen nahe der ostsee
zarnowiec und logo amoco parrino etwa
450 kilometer von berlin entfernt der
erste reaktorblock soll 2033 ans netz
gehen bis 2043 sollen fünf weitere
reaktorblöcke folgen mit diesem schritt
will polen den ausstieg aus der kohle
schaffen und so gibt es für das
bundesumweltministerium weiterhin anders
diesem thema die volle aufmerksamkeit zu
schenken wir müssen auch in zukunft
schnell kompetent und zielgerichtet auf
gefahren aus der atomkraftnutzung
reagieren können insbesondere auf
mögliche akw unfälle im ausland denn
klar ist radioaktivität macht vor
grenzen nicht halt dazu die präsidentin
des bundesamtes für strahlenschutz inge
paulini deshalb müssen wir auch auf
unfälle im europäischen ausland
vorbereitet sein und bei der bewältigung
eines unfalls grenzüberschreitend
zusammenarbeiten
es ist uns ein anliegen mit unserer
expertise internationale partner
organisation zu unterstützen und so ist
das bundesumweltministerium mit am start
die sicherung des havarierten reaktors
in tschernobyl und des darin enthaltenen
kernmaterials zu unterstützen und zu
begleiten doch nicht nur das das
bundesamt für strahlenschutz bfs ist
jetzt zum wiederholten male bei einem
mass einsatz direkt vor ort dabei und
deutsche fachleute haben die messungen
vom dritten bis zum 19 september in der
sperrzone von tschernobyl mit
unterstützt am boden und von
hubschraubern aus wurden verschiedene
daten ermittelt und kartiert zum einen
die höhe der vorhandenen strahlung aber
auch die menge und art der stoffe die
sich da am boden abgelagert haben und
die für diese strahlung verantwortlich
sind fest steht noch immer auf 35 jahre
nach dem unfall gibt es weiterhin
radioaktiv strahlende staubpartikel die
bundespolizei auf fachleute des
bundesamtes für strahlenschutz haben
sich deswegen mit wissenschaftlerinnen
und wissenschaftlern vor ort das ziel
gesetzt eine neue karte mit der
strahlenbelastung zu erstellen wie hat
sich diese im laufe der jahre verändert
unterwegs waren sie im norden der
ukraine die ergebnisse sollen erst im
april des kommenden jahres 2022
vorgestellt werden doch die ersten
analysen zeigen dass die gefahr
offensichtlich noch lange nicht gebannt
ist die beiden hubschrauber der
bundespolizei aus deutschland waren in
den vergangenen wochen täglich vier bis
sechs stunden im einsatz an bord etwa
200 kilogramm schwere messgeräte dazu
heißt es auf der website des bundesamts
für strahlenschutz mit
strahlungsmessungen von hubschraubern
aus lassen sich innerhalb kurzer zeit
große gebiete auf radioaktive
kontaminationen hin untersuchen neben
der schnelligkeit ist von vorteil dass
sich auch gebiete untersuchen lassen die
vom boden aus nicht zugänglich sind in
einem radiologischen notfall kann eine
fläche von rund hundert
quadratkilometern innerhalb von drei
stunden überflogen und kartiert werden
die messresultate liegen bereits kurz
nach der landung vor über den
verunglückten reaktor dürfen die
hubschrauber allerdings nicht fliegen
das ist viel zu gefährlich die
ukrainischen behörden befürchten das
risiko eines möglichen absturz das hier
werden drohnen eingesetzt doch auch die
messungen am boden selbst sind wichtig
dazu der mitarbeiter des bundesamtes für
strahlenschutz christopher strobl wir
nutzen den hubschrauber um einen
überblick zu bekommen und machen
anschließend detaillierte messungen am
boden am boden können wir dann deutlich
detaillierter die radiologische lage
beurteilen mobile team sind am boden
unterwegs um hier 200 ms punkte
abzuarbeiten und die ukrainische
sperrzone ist alles andere als klein sie
entspricht mit ihren rund 2600
quadratkilometern etwa der fläche des
saarlandes die messpunkte werden durch
straßen miteinander verbunden hier
werden dann etwa 15 zentimeter tiefe
proben genommen die dann in zweieinhalb
zentimeter großen schichten unterteilt
werden doch ein hindernis gibt es dabei
noch denn damals ließen die slowenischen
behörden nach der atomkatastrophe große
gebiete umpflügen die fachleute müssen
also zudem prüfen ob der boden an den
jeweiligen messpunkten bearbeitet ist
oder nicht dazu sagt ein beteiligter für
sie ganz deutschland daniel s
je tiefer das cäsium im boden sitzt umso
geringer trägt es zur
hintergrundstrahlung bei die auswertung
der bodenproben erfolgt dann in einem
örtlichen labor und die ersten
ergebnisse lassen nichts gutes ahnen
leben nach könnte sich die cäsium
verteilung die in den 90er jahren
gemessen wurde kaum verändert haben dazu
sagt christopher strobel vom bundesamt
für strahlenschutz das heißt wir haben
das bestätigt was die kollegen damals in
aufopferungsvolle arbeit geleistet haben
doch trotz solcher messergebnisse bleibt
die sperrzone nicht leer sondern hat
sich in den vergangenen jahren sogar als
touristenmagnet etabliert oh my god die
veranstalter solcher trip zum
unglücksreaktor werben mit sprüchen wie
hol dir deinen schuss adrenalin vor zwei
jahren 2009/10 kamen mehr als
120000 touristinnen und touristen nach
tschernobyl das muss man sich mal
vorstellen dabei gibt es beunruhigende
meldungen aus dem havarierten reaktor
block 4 der wissenschaftler in hyatt hat
das in einem interview mit dem
deutschlandfunk so zusammengefasst in
diesem brennstoff haltigen material
beobachten wir einen anstieg des
neutronen flusses es werden also mit der
zeit mehr neutronen imitiert neutronen
können uran und plutonium atome spalten
wodurch weitere neutronen entstehen und
das ist das was gemessen wird eine
nukleare kettenreaktion die sich also
verstärkt die rede ist von einem der
räume in denen dem unfall sah 86 das
gemisch aus stahlstäben kernbrennstoff
und trümmer geflossen ist konkret
bereitet vor allem der raum 305 2 sorge
denn hier ist damals besonders viel
corinne geschlossen gemeint ist damit
das geschmolzene material einer
kernschmelze in einem kernreaktor
doch die messwerte bleiben ein mysterium
denn nicht alle sensoren in diesem raum
verzeichnen denselben anstieg doch einer
der sohn zeigt an dass sich der
entscheidende messwert in den
vergangenen vier jahren sogar verdoppelt
haben könnte den fachleuten bleibt
nichts anderes übrig als diese messdaten
zu interpretieren denn ein zugang in den
raum 305 2 der ist nicht möglich doch
wie kommt es zu diesen erschreckenden
messergebnissen es handelt sich
wahrscheinlich eben um eine nukleare
kettenreaktion die gerade in gang kommt
diese könnte dann den neutronen fluss
verstärken robert kilger von der
gesellschaft für an und
reaktorsicherheit grs sagte im interview
mit dem deutschlandfunk dass im
schlimmsten fall eine dampf explosion
drohen könnte dann nämlich wenn wasser
im zusammenhang mit der kettenreaktion
sehr schnell verdampft der baufällige
sarkophag könnte dann einstürzen das
sind wirklich keine guten nachrichten
alles über die atomkatastrophe gibt es
hier super gau tschernobyl clixoom
science and history anklicken anschauen
und abonnieren das geht ganz einfach mit
dem abo button unter jedem video macht
schlau und kostet nichts bis dann bleibt
dran